foreign
we're going out to Cassie in Cambridge
where they got equations on the walls at
the bars what's up Cassie
hi Dr John are you an MIT kid or a
Harvard kid a Harvard kid
no none at all
I just
I'm not hey I'm not either I'm a state
school guy that's what I'm talking about
hey what's up Cassie
all right
um so I guess my question here is it
sounds weird but I have have you ever
have you ever heard this show yeah I
have yeah I promise whatever you're
about to say you're not the weird one so
bring it on
okay
um so I I have this fear of going
basically going to the doctors
um and it's like super strange but I
will like I'll cancel appointments and
I'll miss appointments because of it and
I don't know like I don't know if this
is
something is there something I can do
before it or if I need to deal with
something or if it's just normal I guess
why are you scared to go to the doctor
why does your body tell you we don't
need to go there
um
well I uh I guess I I had a bad like
pretty bad experiences in the past tell
me about them
yeah
um so
I was in elementary school and I think
part of it is just tell me tell me tell
me
okay
um when I was in elementary school I
struggled with food and just stuff like
that and I ended up Cassie
yes
say it all the way
well I was hospitalized and then for
what for what
this is what I like I can't I can talk
about it but I can't name it so I I
don't know okay so you had a challenge
with food did you restruct with anorexia
or bulimia
uh yeah one of those yeah okay why can't
you say that
I don't know like will you say it right
now
Maybe
go for it
I struggled with some
eating issues
okay
and it led to me being hospitalized for
a couple weeks and then I was thrown
into basically a psych ward but
um
I just had like a really a rough
experience in there
um it was a teenage unit and I was 12 at
the time
and I was I was a good evening she was
when I was younger so I just saw like so
many different things
um in there and it was a really I guess
a really scary scary experience
what was
um
thank you for saying that out loud by
the way I know it was hard okay
um
why are you a Goody Two Shoe
I'm an asset I'm going to set in a hard
direct way is that cool yeah
often Goody Two-Shoes can be a trauma
response
it's a way to keep the boogeyman away
it's a way to keep a scary uncle or a
mom and dad from being on your case from
messing with you if you just do
everything perfect and toe the line and
stay out of the way
um
I always did I did well in school I just
wanted of course you did I like I like
to do well yeah okay
where did the what were the roots in
disordered eating
um what was that a response to
I
I don't know I felt like I was so young
that it doesn't make sense to me okay
okay and there I I've I've recently in
the past year heard some studies that
suggests that may be a
more genetic than we previously thought
we used to subscribe like prescribe it
all to traumas and anxiety response and
that there is some some significant
literature that suggests that has can be
highly genetic that there's really not a
lot of environmental factors but I don't
know enough about it
um here's what's important now are you
healed now are you are you do you have a
good relationship with food now
I would say yeah for the most part I
feel good good do you still struggle
from anorexia or bulimia
I not really only when times are tough
but okay no not really okay
times have been tough for everybody
recently Cassie
yeah so why do you need to go to the
doctor
it's
um it's kind of a regular
major like how
we are this year and what was it I don't
um it wasn't related well I don't know
if it was or wasn't related I they say
it wasn't but I always feel super guilty
that I caused the issue
um
what's the issue
so I I basically I had a growth in my
body
um that required
surgery but I guess I'm like this is my
kind of my fault because I waited until
the growth became massive until I went
to the doctors
um to get it checked out
I don't you and I could spend some time
together I know but
you don't like Cassie
and I don't like that you don't like
Cassie because I like Cassie
and I like I think
are Pleasant with her
but you think she does a lot of stuff
wrong
I think some she could be better in some
ways yeah
wanting to improve on things is one
thing be better is a totally different
proposition
is that fair
yeah yeah
so here's like the last couple of times
or there's been a couple of times in
your life that you've gone to the doctor
one of them has ended in a surgery that
you have shame over
another time ended up in a
hospitalization and you probably heard
it from your parents about how expensive
it was and how they wanted me to quit
their job and they had to right it
caused a major
um
upheaval in your home that somehow was
transferred onto you this is your fault
not we're your parents and we love you
and it's our job to take care of you to
the ends of the Earth that's what we
signed up for when we had you
but
if you you're fine just eat or just just
like write those kind of things
and here you are now
and
you need to go to the doctor
and your body's put some GPS pins in the
doctor's offices as though they are the
problem
and I'd love to reframe that and say no
um you had some scary experiences as a
kid and it probably wasn't a good idea
for you it wasn't a good idea for a 12
year old to be put on the
on a psych ward with teenagers
the number of students over the years
that I I sat with in psych wards that
were like Oh I thought I wasn't okay but
whoa after spending two nights in a side
Court they're like I'm fine right I
don't have that
um is I mean all but like a handful had
that experience and I can only imagine
how terrifying that was for a 12 year
old
right
the phobia is Real This fear is real and
there is one way to heal from it
and it's to go right through it
okay and I know that's the worst
possible answer you can get
here's um what I have found in my life
um
is you have to teach your body that it's
okay to go now it wasn't then it's okay
now
that's what healing from trauma is I can
walk in and I can feel my heart rate
getting up I can feel my hands I can
feel myself picking up my phone to
cancel and I'm not going to I'm gonna
feel it and what we're going to do over
the course of a few
um visits is we're going to retrain our
body the doctors are trustworthy and
they're okay
and that if I do have to have surgery
thank goodness there's a group of people
who's dedicated their lives to keeping
people like me safe
right it's a total reframe from oh God
if I go there they're going to cut
another big lump of my body out of me
it's man thank goodness they are are
keeping me safe and I'm gonna feel it
and I'm gonna feel it and I'm gonna feel
it and here's the other thing
disorder eating has a way of isolating
us creating a space between us and
relationships and us and the rest of the
world fair
yeah
yeah and I've struggled with disordered
eating almost my entire life
okay and I only recently started talking
about that publicly it's been a mess
okay I tell you that to tell you I can
be in a crowded room completely by
myself because I am so preoccupied with
judging how I look and how I'm standing
and how I'm moving right yeah okay the
only way through that is to open up to
other people
and now I come out of my room and I look
at my wife and say is this shirt okay to
wear and she says yes
and
I let I trust her more than my feelings
and I'm learning I'm in the process
right now in my 40s of learning
how to trust and how to feel what a
shirt feels like to fit that doesn't
feel awkward that you know what I mean
that's where you are and we're gonna
practice
practice relationships so I have found
walking through anxiety walking through
phobias walking through those moments
I can only do it with somebody else with
me by my side
okay and so it's making an appointment
to go to the doctor and calling a friend
and saying I need you to come here and
um set up an appointment for me or I
need you to call and make an appointment
for me on the first two or three while
I'm learning and that way I can't call
and cancel them only you can and then I
need you to come pick me up because I'm
not going to get in the car
is actually a good idea just here's what
we're doing we're owning reality and
reality is right now
um I can't stop eating sugar I'm just
throwing that out there so I'm gonna
take all the sugar out of my house
I can't right now and you can but it
feels like you can
I can't make a good choice when it comes
to seeing a doctor because every time I
make an appointment my whole body
freezes on me and tenses up because the
last few times I've gone it's been a
disaster
both financially and physically
so hey I need you to make this
appointment for me or do it with me and
then I need you to drive me would you
come pick me up would you walk alongside
me during this during this time would
you be in the in the room with me would
you sitting there with me
um well the doctor gives me the news
um I'd really appreciate that and then
our bodies are going to see that we are
not alone our bodies are going to see
that that doctor's got our best interest
at heart our body's going to see that
we're more well after we visit our
doctor than before
and then it's going to learn over time
oh Cassie's driving now Cassie's in
control
doctors aren't the end of the world I
had a bad experience a real bad
experience once and they saved my life
the next time
they're forming out against me and we're
just teaching our body that
Your brave brave young woman I would
also recommend find a local counselor in
your area and let them know I really
struggle with some historical trauma
here I don't know where it's from I
don't know why
um I still struggle with disorder eating
every once in a while
when things get stressed and things are
always stressed
and I want some practical tips on
breathing through and box breathing and
dropping my shoulders when I've got to
do hard things like make doctor's
appointments and actually show up make
counseling appointments and actually
show up
because we can't do Life by ourselves
Cassie we can't gotta have other people
professionals and Friends
moms and dads and romantic Partners we
need everybody